[Music]
kids can be absolutely hilarious and
sometimes their answers can take an
unexpected turn
wait until you see some of the funniest
kids test answers ever including ones
that were so full of attitude we
seriously wonder what their teachers did
after reading it do you know the correct
answer to these give this video a thumbs
up and hit that subscribe button to
never miss another video again now let's
check out 20 most hilarious kids test
answers that made even the teacher laugh
the strongest force on earth what is
love baby don't hurt me don't hurt me no
more this kid is either super funny or
totally in love for extra credit they
had to answer what the strongest force
on earth was and of course they answered
that it was love unfortunately the
teacher didn't agree with them but we
definitely give them that extra credit
if nothing else they deserved it for
making their answer go viral and in case
you're wondering the strongest force on
earth is called strong nuclear however
overall there are four strongest
fundamental interactions that operate on
earth including electromagnetic weak
nuclear and gravitational not only will
you get two laughs today will also give
you all the right answers I like to move
it this looks like it was a simple
English lesson the person had to
brainstorm verbs and write down what
they liked to do with their friends and
family to practice using verbs in a
sentence
but this kid seemed to have a better
idea you're welcome because the I like
to move it song will now be stuck in
your head for the rest of your day to be
fair this was a totally hilarious answer
and we hope they managed to get an extra
point or at least make the teacher laugh
they definitely deserved it further
amazing creativity here's an extra point
for us because we like to move it -
amazing excuse sometimes you just don't
know the answer to the question because
you haven't studied or for whatever
other reason this kid was supposed to
explain how the nitrogen atom in the
upper atmosphere becomes useful to an
archaeologist trying to determine the
age of a bone instead of answering this
student gave an impressive excuse and
says if they didn't go over this problem
when they were studying and didn't pay
attention in class but they don't stop
there they continue to say that they
don't even like science but they do like
the teacher and they hope this won't
ruin their friendship then they
for some dating advice we're pretty sure
this kid was sent to the principal's
office after this plant sell this child
was told to draw plant cell and identify
its most important parts if you don't
know what a plant cell is you'd be
confused too it seems like this kid
skipped class on the day they learned
about plant cells and decided to take
the assignment literally it's a plant in
an actual cell that has no windows and
iron bars in case you're wondering a
plant cell looks like this and comes
with several important parts like the
cell wall vacuole chloroplasts and
nucleus all those parts are essential to
the function of the plants although
we're pretty sure we prefer this kids
answer to that question Abraham Lincoln
although this wasn't a test it did make
us giggle this child was asked to think
about living in the same time as Abraham
Lincoln he also had to say what he'd
tell him while most people would love to
get advice on the country and culture
this child had a totally different
answer that would actually save Abraham
Lincoln at least for some time the kid
gave advice that he should never attend
any kinds of plays ever who knows
perhaps this advice would actually keep
Abraham Lincoln alive and history would
be changed forever
forgetting sometimes kids test answers
are just so clever we really hope they
got an extra credit for it Bryan was
told to describe what it meant by
forgetting something but his answer
wasn't the typical one all Bryan said
was that he can't remember and to be
honest he's right that is in fact the
description of forgetting something of
course the real answer would be
something like not being able to recall
the memories in your brain but honestly
we like Bryan straight-to-the-point
answer better we're not seeing any extra
credit for a tick next to his answer but
we do hope this teacher had a good laugh
after reading Bryan's answers I of
sauron this physics class just got 10
times better
this child had to draw a graph to
explain what happens upon impact when we
wear a seatbelt or when we don't wear a
seatbelt in the car it looks like this
was all a piece of cake for this kid and
he ended up with extra time so they
decided to draw the Eye of Sauron
clearly this teacher is a total lord of
the Rings fan because they knew how
dangerous it was to draw something like
that or maybe they were just upset that
the kid didn't take their tests
seriously or not
well played Alex well played how do you
know sometimes teachers want us to show
our thinking by explaining how we can
with our answers this kid had to answer
questions like how many days there are
in a week how many months are in a year
and whether the number 68 is an even
number or an odd number of course their
answers were all correct but when they
were asked how they know that 68 is an
even number the kid replied with a
simple answer because they're smart well
they're not wrong but it looks like the
teacher didn't want to put up with any
of the attitude and provided them with
the right answer instead shape of the
graph this is a typical graph you
normally see in a physics class and it
represents the relation between mass and
time through these graphs students are
able to read off specific measurements
and make a calculation of other
functions depending on the question but
this student definitely didn't
understand the assignment instead of
describing the shape of the graph by
stating that the mass reduces the time
they describe the graph literally we
love that the student thought the slope
was rather aesthetically pleasing which
is true of course that's not the right
answer but they deserve extra credit for
this thorough essay communism get ready
because these answers are going to get
even funnier and more creative we're not
sure whether or not this person got an
extra credit for their answer but they
definitely should this child was asked
to describe a situation where people
share something and everyone benefits
from it and from what it looks like this
was a chemistry question this kid must
have paid attention during history
classes because they said the answer is
communism of course we all know
communism works only on paper because
there's always someone out there that's
greedier than others so this kid should
definitely get at least half a point for
their answer ninja sometimes it might
surprise you how easy it is to get extra
points with certain teachers this kid
thought of a brilliant idea not only did
they already get 28 out of 30 points on
their exam this ninja brought them two
extra points this kid wrote that the
ninja prevents the teacher to give a
grade that's lower than 100% and the
teacher definitely listened and awarded
them with two extra points if only all
teachers were able to joke like that and
award points for creativity on the other
hand this also means that tests aren't
all about knowing everything
sometimes your drawing skills can save
your grade Mariah Carey Mariah Carey is
definitely known for her whistle tones
but is she able to produce the highest
frequency noise this kid sure seems to
think so we wonder if Mariah Carey ever
saw this answer because quite frankly
this is one of the best compliments ever
while it's true that mariah carey's high
notes can even compare to a dolphin's
pitch the answer to this question is a
little bit different the highest
frequency a human can register goes from
20 Hertz up to 20,000 Hertz depending on
the person's age and plenty of other
factors in case you're wondering mariah
carey's highest note has a frequency of
an impressive 3,300 Hertz evolution this
kid was asked to describe two evidences
for evolution but instead of giving the
right answer the kid draws something
that could be considered a de evolution
they also say that they studied this and
still forgot it and then drew a smurf
pointing to a brain saying it's all the
brain's folds the correct answer would
be fossil evidence which were first
discovered in the 17th century another
evidence of evolution would be similar
characteristics and related organisms
unfortunately this explanation doesn't
include Smurfs pointing at brains but we
have to admit this was a hilarious
answer hope they get credit for their
creative side Tracy we're pretty sure
this teachers blood started to boil
after reading this answer this kid was
given a mathematical question but their
answer turned into something every
feminist had a problem with the child
was supposed to resolve why Tracy's
answers are wrong by giving an example
of the calculation process but this
child wasn't having any of that instead
they wrote their own reasoning why Tracy
was wrong because she's a woman
we hope this kid got a few minus points
and a word with their teacher for this
answer because we definitely have a few
questions for them or maybe this kid
should participate in the event
suggested in our next test answer hunger
games this kid seems to be a huge fan of
Suzanne Collins and the Hunger Games
franchise although it's true that the
question itself is pretty bizarre this
answer seems to be on point for any fan
of the Hunger Games the kid was asked to
provide the best solution for
overpopulation and supported with
arguments of course a better answer
would be to spread awareness and
providing universal access to birth
control devices but this child seems to
think having a real-life hunger games
would solve the issue to be fair even
though the solution is definitely not
humane the kid has a point named them
when asked to name the quadrilaterals
hope took that question literally it
definitely happens more than you think
but it also provides us
some of the most hilarious kids test
answers ever there are six types of
quadrilaterals out there there's a
rectangle a parallelogram a rhombus a
square a trapezoid and a kite those
names can also be found on the right
side of the question
but according to hope the quadrilaterals
have a different name they're called Bob
Sam Ted esand Kate and Harry we bet the
teacher had a laugh with this one but we
also hope that hope knows the actual
names to those quadrilaterals a plus for
creativity sometimes teachers do end up
giving extra credit for creativity and
we absolutely love it when it happens
this is one of our favorite exams of all
time even though this kid got an F they
got an A+ for creativity according to
them Napoleon died in his last battle
the Declaration of Independence was
signed on the bottom of the page their
main reason for divorce is marriage and
the main reason for exams is failure
they're not wrong but according to their
teacher they're clearly not right either
we agree that they definitely deserve an
A+ for creativity even though their
answers aren't correct treasure
sometimes kids like to take a risk with
their answers but other times they're
just pointing out the obvious it makes
us wonder if we're actually overthinking
stuff and the answers to complicated
questions are much more simple this
child was asked to guide Davey Bo's the
dog to his treasure their problem was
the test didn't specify that the dog
should be guided through the treasure so
technically this kid didn't even do
anything wrong they simply connected the
dog to the treasure without bothering to
go through the complicated maze it's the
simplest way to solve any kind of
problem and we definitely love this
answer freeloader when Frankie was asked
how she earns money at home she replied
that she doesn't it makes sense right
judging by her handwriting
Frankie is probably too young to work
outside of doing regular house chores
but she also replied with that she
doesn't earn money because she's a
freeloader which is absolutely hilarious
a freeloader is a person who takes
advantage of others generosity without
giving anything in return
which is basically exactly what kids are
but what's even more hilarious is that
the kids know what the word freeloader
means in the first place this is
definitely one of our top hilarious kids
test answers math but nothing beats kids
who are able to write down an answer
that challenges Authority we've seen
quite a few of those in this video but
this is one of our favorites we
no idea who this kid is but we'd love to
meet them they knew that the difference
between 180 and 158 is 22 which seems to
be pretty obvious but when asked how
they got to their answer the kid didn't
use calculations to support their
argument they just said that they got
the answer by using math which is
definitely correct
they really do deserve at least one
extra point for their clever answer
which answer is your favorite let us
know in the comments and that's it for
our video for more videos like this one
check out 20 toys no kid would want to
receive on Christmas see you next time
[Music]